The first time you saw rational expressions in this course, was way early on
when we looked at rational inequalities. At this point I think we've setup a
great framework for us to understand rational inequalities a lot better than we
did before. So let's look at one now. How about this one. 2x minus 3 over x
minus 5 is greater than 0. Now I'd like us to find the solution set for this
inequality. All of the values of x that make this inequality true. To refresh
your memory on how to do this, first I'd like you to find the critical values
for this inequality. The values for x that make either the denominator or the
numerator equal 0. These critical values split the number line into intervals.
So check a value within each interval to see if it satisfies the inequality.
Based on this, you can write the solution in inequality form. Remember that you
can write backslash or and then a space, if you want to join inequalities or
chain them together, if there's more than one region in the solution. Write
your answer in this green box.